[Musik]
das podcast ist platin blm juni also
meine damen und herren ich begrüße sie
es ist hier die vorlesungsreihe über
kapitalismuskritik und ich bin der
dozent juli nobitz vorab ein paar
organisatorische elemente also sie
können falls sie wollen in dieser
veranstaltung etc punkte erwerben oder
sich scheine ausstellen lassen oder was
auch immer die details wissen sie
wahrscheinlich besser als ich aber ein
wichtiger punkt ist dass zu diesem
angebot gehört auch eine
begleitveranstaltung wenn sie vorhaben
eine schriftliche arbeit einzureichen
also das heißt protokoll
aber es ist dann vielleicht ein bisschen
anspruchsvoller es nur etwas zum
protokollieren aber jedenfalls wenn sie
das machen wollen dann ist es meine
empfehlung dass sie auch in die
begleitveranstaltung so weit wie möglich
gehen
das ist aber keine vorbedingungen sie
können das auch ohne
aber jedenfalls geleitet wird die
zeitgleich die begleitveranstaltung
durch viele der hier vorne sitzt und das
sind sie sehr willkommen ok dazu noch
ganz kurz ein paar bemerkungen also wenn
sie ein protokoll schreiben wollen dann
sollten sie bitte das thema den bereich
mit uns absprechen
am ende des semesters ist also nicht
dass sie denken na ja gut ich schreibe
ein protokoll für die erste
veranstaltung und das war es dann
das muss schon etwas mehr sein als das
der zweite punkt ist im rahmen der
begleiter veranstaltung schreiben sie
auch einen gerne einen probe auf's oder
probe protokoll oder was auch immer
einreichen das ist manchmal ganz
hilfreich oder eine übung das ist ein
angebot müssen sie nicht machen aber das
ist eine möglichkeit die sie wahrnehmen
können wenn sie wollen
aber auch dann ist der gedanke des
übungsplatzes nicht dass sie mit unserer
hilfe das protokoll vorweg nehmen
sondern dass sie über machen protokoll
hat ein anderes thema ok dann noch ein
letzter punkt bitte behalten sie das
vorlesungsverzeichnis das elektronische
im auge
für den fall dass kurzfristig ein termin
ausfallen sollte ich muss sie jetzt
waren dann irgendwann im mai wird einen
termin ausfallen
aus dienstlichen gründen ich weiß
allerdings noch nicht genau wann
behalten sie es im auge
nächste woche fällt sowieso außer ist
ein feiertag ist ja und ein letzter
punkt wie sie sehen können
die vorlesung wird per video aufgenommen
und sie können die verletzten auch dann
wieder abrufen von der webseite der
fakultät wenn sie wollen
natürlich besteht auch die möglichkeit
dass sie gar nicht in die vorlesung
physisch kommen sondern immer nur im
netz abrufen steht ihnen gerne zu ich
würde sagen für mich ist natürlich
angenehmer wenn ich tatsächlich personen
vor mir ab und nicht nur die kamera aber
so ist es halt
zweiter punkt es geht hier um eine
philosophische veranstaltung
das bedeutet das heißt nicht dass es so
gekommen ist wäre ihnen unter umständen
möglicherweise die methode ein bisschen
fremd sind
der philosophie ist nicht antworten zu
bieten sondern fragen zu verstehen also
das seit sokrates das ist die
dialektische methode die philosophie ist
dazu da um fragen zu verstehen ob man
dank seiner antwort kommt oder nicht ist
gewissermaßen sekundär
das bedeutet unter anderem
benzin arbeit schreiben oder wenn sie
sich äußern ist vor allem
voreingenommenheit und dogmatik und
solche sachen zu vermeiden
also wenn ich das ganz brutal sagen darf
wenn sie eine arbeit einreichen sollten
wenn das gilt auch für meine methode
interessiert mich ihre meinung überhaupt
nicht ja das ist wirklich nicht ihre
aufgabe meinungen zu entwickeln oder
lehrmeinungen aufzubauen was nicht
interessiert ist das problem dass sie
erfasst haben und hoffentlich
verständnisvoll verarbeitet haben
und das betreute im rahmen der
philosophie gerade dass sie konflikten
auf stellen also für die philosophie
sind themen interessant so weit sie
konflikte preisgeben
etwas was sicher ist oder was sie als
sicher da stellen ist einfach nicht mehr
interessant also die dialektik schon in
der klassischen philosophie
gewissermaßen auch weiterhin dann bei
hegel vielleicht sogar bei marx aber das
ist jetzt egal der punkt ist die
dialektik ist die methode der
philosophie im gegensatz zu den meisten
wissenschaften die meisten
wissenschaften arbeiten nicht
dialektisch sondern streben eine antwort
das tut die philosophie nicht meine
natürlich sind argumentativ
leidenschaftlich vorgetragene standpunkt
und interessantes element in einer
diskussion ich meine wenn man immer nur
sagen oder ich weiß es nicht so kritisch
dann würde keine diskussion zustande
kommen das ist schon klar aber wenn sie
ein stand kommt erarbeiten dann will ich
auch die gegenseite
sonst ist die erste seite leer das nun
vorab das thema ist dann
kapitalismuskritik und philosophie und
ich werde jetzt nicht irgendwelche
positionen referiert wieder gegen den
kapitalismus oder oder für als sei das
dann die antwort sondern möchte einfach
ein bisschen eruieren was sich hier
alles entwickelt und an gegner schafften
und kontroversen und die kontroverse die
kontroversen im rahmen
ach so
also die kontroversen im rahmen des
kapitalismus und kapitalismuskritik sind
natürlich heute durchaus wieder aktuell
also eine zeit lang vielleicht weniger
aber jetzt inzwischen spielen sie sogar
eine rolle in der amerikanischen politik
das länger nicht mehr der fall war also
sie haben sicherlich mitbekommen dass
nichts anderes ich beispielsweise als
demokratisch socialist bezeichnet und
socialist ist sehr stark im gegensatz
zum kapital ist gedacht und auch die
alexandra casio cortés 29 jahre alt die
letztes jahr in den kongress gewählt
wurde
die zeit bezeichnet sich auch als
demokratisch socialist und lehnt den
kapitalismus ab weil sie sagt der
kapitalismus ist nicht nachhaltig
irgendwann wird der kapitalismus uns
alle ins desaster stürzen wieder immer
nennt aus dem aus den widersprüchen des
systems oder weil der kapitalismus
zeigen einfach nicht die probleme
brachte die uns jetzt akut betreffen
hauptsächlich natürlich in der
klimakrise
also das ist etwas was jetzt sind
aktuell in der amerikanischen politik
eine wichtige rolle spielt das haben sie
sicherlich mitbekommen
auch in der wissenschaft da gibt es auch
prominente vertreter von beiden seiten
also solche die sich als kapital
kapitalismus kritiker bezeichnen würden
und andere die nicht unbedingt
kapitalisten sind aber jedenfalls der
meinung sind dass attacken auf den
kapitalismus in die falsche richtung
gehen dafür beispiele
während ein kritiker des kapitalismus
gewissermaßen ist der slowenische
philosoph slavoj zizek juliana und
london und über und einer der auf der
anderen seite steht ist der kanadische
psychologe dort anbieters und sie haben
möglicherweise erst letzte woche ist
eine debatte hat eine debatte
stattgefunden zwischen den beiden in
toronto die jetzt auf youtube steht das
könnten sie sich vielleicht mal
anschauen wenn sie kurz kam
sie sind zweieinhalb stunden aber beide
ist ein ganz sympathischer redner und es
ist nicht uninteressant
also bei da geht es allerdings keine
besonders zuge späteste debatte ich
meine es klingt so als würde blut
fließen noch hinsichtlich haben dass
auch viele der zuhörer erwartet es waren
enorm viele zuschauer diesen zulauf
was dabei herauskam war wie gesagt keine
keine so scharfe konfrontation aber
interessante ist auf jeden fall dass
jürgen peters
quasi seine analyse des kommunistischen
manifests von karl marx dargestellt hat
ja und da hätte man da hat mein text
kann man sich auch anschauen und dann
hören was glauben peters und dazu sagt
ich würde allerdings sagen ich finde der
tatsächlich nicht so wahnsinnig
überzeugend von ihnen aus konnten die
wir vielleicht noch vertiefen werden
aber die auch hier gibt es erst mal
darum dass das jetzt schon eine aktuelle
debatte ist inwiefern das etwas mit
populismus und donald trump und solche
sachen zu tun hat weiß ich nicht mehr so
offen lassen aber auf jeden fall ist wie
gesagt kombi ist kommt das wieder stark
zum forscher diejenigen unter uns die
schon ein bisschen älter sind ist das
ist der gedanke des kapitalismus als es
wirklich ganz wesentlicher inhalt gerade
an den hochschulen auch nichts neues
und das sind dann deswegen der gedanke
wir sollten wir können uns gerne noch
mal ein bisschen befassen mit den
profiliertesten kapital ja doch
kapitalismuskritiker des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts in deutschland nämlich
adorno und habermas ist eindeutig ein
kritiker des kapitalismus bei habe aus
geht es mir auch etwas anderer china war
aber trotzdem damals in den 70ern 80ern
sehr einflussreich und ist es vielleicht
gewissermaßen immer noch okay jetzt zu
den quellen und texten die ich ihnen
gerne nahelegen würde also wirklich
jeder lesen sollte wenn er oder sie es
noch nicht gelesen hat ist das
kommunistische manifest das ist einfach
und bezugspunkt das gehört heute oder
gehört schon seit langem zur
allgemeinbildung herzlich egal was sie
für eine politische einstellung haben
das muss man gelesen haben
es ist nicht lang und ob sie zu
überzeugen finden oder nicht ist
nachfrage sind dort ebenfalls wichtige
themen aus denen man was machen kann
ich würde vielleicht im vorfeld auch ein
bisschen mit dem mit rücksicht auf otten
peters dazu vielleicht doch zwei worte
vorab sagen also mach es kommt es kommt
jetzt in meiner erfolge etwas später mir
zuerst nicht mit klassikern der
kapitalismus analyse auseinandersetzen
aber marx ist ist wirklich ein wegweiser
nach vorne und nach hinten
also ist wenn sie das kommende kommen
ließen werden
kasachen wahrnehmen also das eine ist
man assoziiert oder ist es ist also
gerade das tut auch dem petersen
es ist sieht man macht es sich zu
einfach wenn man sagt na ja das mag zwar
ein kommunist der sich selber als
kommunist erklärt hat auch zur
revolution aufgerufen und in folge
dieses aufrufes kam es gerade im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert zu den absoluten
menschlichen diktatorischen
entwicklungen also stichwort stalin aber
vielleicht braucht entwicklungen in ost
[Musik]
aber wie auch immer also das argument
ist also stalin hat genauso viele
menschen umgebracht wie hitler als mit
anderen begründungen aber so destruktiv
war er auch und wendet der kommunismus
so etwas zulässt dann muss irgendwas
falsch sein
ok also ja meine man könnte vielleicht
das gleiche über die katholische kirche
an
solche argumente sind ein bisschen
gefährlich wie auch immer gesagt dass
jedes argument sollte geprüft werden und
das ist in ordnung das gehört zur
dialektik
ich würde aber nur in weisen die
programmpunkte im kommunistischen
manifest ende des zweiten teils
er hat zehn programmpunkte die
eigentlich auch heute oder gerade heute
inzwischen fast selbstverständlich sind
also die sind ja ja einige sind mehr
selbstverständlich als andere
erstens export reaktion des
grundeigentums also enteignen um zum
gemeinwohl kennt man also gibt es in
deutschland gibt es eigentlich in allen
ländern das man enteignen kann
allerdings bei ihm ist es bei marx ist
es die grundsätzliche ex enteignung von
grundeigentum überhaupt und dann die
verwendung der grundrente also der
bieterin aus dem grund zu staatsausgaben
das klingt etwas befremdlich ist in der
praxis ist das gibt es in gleicher gab
es schon ich weiß nicht ob es damals
schon gab aber in england wird grund
besteuert wie auch in deutschland
allerdings in england wird auf der basis
einer theoretischen miete besteuert und
das dann vom staat eingenommen
das ist nicht ganz eine enteignung
allerdings in england ist es auch so
dass theoretisch kann man keinen eigenen
also jetzt streng juristisch kann man
den eltern kein keinen grund eigentum
besitzen das gibt es nicht dass gehört
nämlich alles der krone
man hat also dass der eigene in
anführungszeichen von grund in england
ist halt nur das café simpel ist quasi
eine lizenz dieses grund zu verwenden
ja es ist aber kein eigentum im strikten
sinne insofern gut ob magst das sind
ein teil also das gefordert das ist
wahrscheinlich zweifelhaft aber
ebenfalls die besteuerung von grund ist
und dass enteignen zum gemeinwohl ist
ist nichts besonders anstößig ist
zweitens eine starke progressiv steuer
haben
drittens abschaffung des erbrechts naja
abgeschafft ist er brecht nicht aber
einschränkungen durch besteuerung ist
auch eine selbstverständlichkeit zum zur
problematik des erbrechts gibt es
allerdings noch sehr viel zu sagen
gerade auch bei den klassischen denkern
konzentration des eigentums aller
emigranten und rebellen
ok also das klingt schon ein bisschen
seltsam aber ob das jetzt unbedingt in
den kommunismus zusammenhängt weiß man
nicht fünfter zentralisation des kredits
in den händen des staates gibt es auch
also nicht zentralisiert aber
staatsbanken oder förderbanken oder die
kfw und so weiter auch eine
selbstverständlichkeit in deutschland
sechs zentralisation das transportwesen
sind den händen des staates also das
hatten wir eben heißt es gab mal in der
bundes die bundesbahn gibt es immer noch
weitgehend privatisiert aber dass das
transportwesen hände staates sein sollte
war zumindest vor 30 jahren überhaupt
nichts ungewöhnliches sieben vermehrung
der national fabriken ja eigentlich dass
das eine ziemlich in effiziente
vorgehensweise ist das weiß man
inzwischen aber nochmal so wahnsinnig
anstößig ist das nicht unbedingt achten
das gleiche arbeitszwang für alle dann
wieder doch ein bisschen bedenklich
aber die amerikaner erwarten ja
schließlich auch dass leute die von der
stütze leben auch arbeiten zunehmend ist
das auch in england der fall
aber das geht natürlich nur für die
armen der gemacht
die reichen sollten gezwungen werden zu
arbeiten das klingt dann wieder ein
bisschen die mauer zu tun aber okay
nicht sehr attraktiv neuen verstehe ich
nicht ganz vereinigung der des betriebs
von ackerbau und industrie und sind ganz
radikal öffentlicher und unentgeltlicher
erziehung aller kindern beseitigung der
fabrikarbeit der kinder
das war der zehnte punkt okay machen sie
daraus was sie wollen aber jedenfalls
ist nicht so
oder sie sollten nicht unbedingt von
vornherein denken na ja das
kommunistische manifest ist ebenso was
ganz radikales und geführt zu desaster
das sollte mal lieber man sollte sich
gar nicht
damit befassen bitte tun sie es lesens
ist und machen sie sich gedanken
ok gut also dass wie gesagt ist es mir
eine große hilfe wenn ich darauf nicht
beziehen kann
in dem in den weiteren police umgefallen
ist
sofern es notwendig ist jetzt möchte ich
ein paar quellen nennen
auch die ich mich auch beziehen werde
marx im neunzehnten jahrhundert ist der
ist das von gedankengängen die vor allem
in der englischen und schottischen
tradition schon erhebliche vorarbeiten
arbeit geleistet hat und die wichtigsten
denker in diesem zusammenhang und es
sind philosophen also das ist jetzt der
philosophische angst als die die moderne
wirtschaftswissenschaft kommt aber aus
der philosophie okay der erste hier oben
ich habe den namen aufgeschrieben
der erste wichtige denke ist denker ist
schon lockt im 17 jahrhundert vor allem
in seine dritte saison gewann traktat
über das regieren von 1690
und das ist ein ganz wichtiges werk john
lobb dass das denken über eigentum
emanzipiert von der vorstellung es ist
halt gott gegeben und wird vererbt also
das quasi blind der bindende gedanke
jedenfalls sowie lockt das darstellt von
früheren denker war gott hat es so
verfügt in der ganzen hierarchie ihre
menschen oben stehen es steht der könig
oder kaiser oder corps oder was auch
immer
dann kommen die adelige nannten sind die
mehr oder weniger versklavten arbeiter
und das ist so vorgesehen
und das setzt sich fort durch vererbung
also eigentums gegenstand von vererbung
das ist das was bis lockt ein
gewissermaßen jedem fall so wie er es
darstellt
selbstverständlich ist aber lockt kommt
nicht in einer ganz neuen idee und sagt
von vornherein besitzt jeder mensch nur
das was er erarbeiten kann
die vorstellung der arbeit also arbeit
wird bei lok zur grundlage des eigentums
was ich mir arbeiten aneignen kann
das gehört mehr und das ist die basis es
gibt keine andere basis also göttliche
fügung oder sonst kann ich vergessen es
ist die menschliche arbeit die eigens
kreiert und da alle menschen
das ist ein thema ist fortan wieder
kommt also arbeit ist es eine ganz
wichtige thema in diesem klassischen
quellen und dann wieder auch bei marks
aber erstens geht mir gesagt eigentums
egger ist ist ein ausdruck von arbeit
von der zweite punkt ist weil es gibt
viele punkte in diesem in diesem
zusammenhang ein ganz wichtiger punkt
mitarbeit ist es wenn man den die
menschen als arbeitende kräfte ansieht
dann sind die menschen eigentlich alle
mehr oder weniger gleich ja gleichheit
kommt aus dem gedanken dass ein mensch
sich in arbeit konstituiert und das auch
eigentum aus der arbeit
entsteht und weil alle gleich sind also
alle haben mehr oder weniger die gleiche
körper stärke also natürlich gibt es
unterschiede aber im wesentlichen sind
menschen körperlich und geistig vielmehr
haben viel mehr gemeinsam als als es was
sie voneinander unterscheidet das ist
ein thema das immer wieder wiederholt
wird die gleichheit ist die gleichheit
dessen was den menschen als es ist ihr
ausmacht und in der arbeit dann kommen
diese diese fähigkeiten geschicklichkeit
'nen was auch immer hin zum auszug und
die unterschiede wie gesagt es sind viel
geringer ist das als die gemeinsamkeiten
deswegen gleich heute okay also da ist
es dann bei lockt natürlich schon eine
herausforderung gegenüber der standes
gesellschaft gegenüber der artist
gesellschaft ging bei einer feudalen
gesellschaft wo eigentumsverhältnisse
und soziale ringe für immer fixiert sind
das dass das sind die elemente die die
gesellschaft zusammenhält in der ältere
der älteren verfassung aber bei lok ist
es deine gedanken ein
die menschen sind gleich und sie sind
erwerben eigentum nur deswegen weil sie
arbeiten ja und sagt auch also das was
ich hier durch arbeit aneignen
berichten des bodens oder oder was auch
immer das gehört mir das ist dann schon
mein eigentum aber nicht mehr
zunächst steht mir zu nur so viel land
sowie grund die ich auch bearbeiten kann
nicht mehr als das ich darf nicht einem
anderen etwas wegnehmen einfach ja so
empfunden auch immer wenn wenn ich es
nicht bearbeiten kann
also das ist schon relativ radikaler
gedanke natürlich kommt dann die
spannende frage
ja was ist dann mit den tatsächlichen
verhältnissen eigentlich ist es schon so
dass viele einige sehr reich sind und
die meisten sehr wenig haben
wie kann man das rechtfertigen nach dem
gedanken von block und das ist eine
spannung innerhalb seiner theorien die
sich nicht auflöst aber die da bleibt
als focus für die überlegungen der
nachfolger ok also dass nur ganz kurz
der zweite klassische denker und das ist
der wahrscheinlich am wichtigsten ist
ist dann adams mir ist ein schotte der
auch outlook aufgebaut hat
in seinem hauptwerk also leitungsnetz
war professor der logik der
wissenschaftler wegen eines fehlers
seine sein werk über moralische
empfindungen ist von herausragender
wichtigkeit also er war ein mitglied der
schottischen aufklärung networkers david
hume also eine gruppe von schottischen
philosophen mitte des neunzehnten
jahrhundert wahnsinnig einflussreich
daher muss es halt dann als spätwerk
eben sein werk über die wie heißt es auf
der station
deutschland wo ich dann der nation
beliebig oft übersetzt worden also diese
ganzen texte kriegen sie ja sowieso im
internet müssen sie nur ausdrucken
aber jetzt werden smith ist folgendes
wichtig die frage also bei john law
kommt jetzt arbeit als zentrale
zentraler begriff zum vorschein
und da ist sie bleibt die spannende
frage ja was ist das was jetzt nicht
unmittelbar zu meiner gegenwärtigen
arbeit gehört also okay ich gehe jetzt
ins feld und ernte welche früchte oder
oder versorger oder sonst was aber was
ist was ist mit sachen die mir irgendwie
dann gehören oder was ist mit
akkumuliert angehäuften gegenständen des
reichtums die nicht unmittelbar zu
dieser arbeit gehören
ok dann sagt smith ja das ist natürlich
eigentlich noch wichtiger weil es ist
nur auf der basis dass quasi die
vergangenheit oder in der vergangenheit
aufgehäufte güter ermöglichen ein
produktives arbeiten heute ja also jeder
mensch der nur quasi ist einen körper
hat vielleicht auch etwas übernimmt
etwas aus der vergangenheit
aber um zu arbeiten braucht der mensch
auch beispielsweise was zum essen muss
was im kühlschrank sein wo kommt das her
es kommt aus der vergangenheit also die
vergangenheit gibt uns die basis ist
dass wir in der zukunft das was draus
machen können
und umso mehr also das ist ein
das essen essen und trinken ist eine
basis aus der vergangenheit für diese
arbeit und natürlich in einem in einem
industriellen system also wo das alles
noch weiter ausgebaut wird wo wir
fabriken haben
dann brauche ich viel mehr als nur etwas
im kühlschrank
ich brauche dann räumlichkeiten wo ich
arbeiten kann ich brauch maschinen
ich brauch rohmaterialien die ich
einkaufe usw
diese ganzen elemente die passen nicht
mehr zur loks darstellung dass alleine
für sich in der landschaft
wirtschaftende personen das schon ein
bisschen mehr als das
also diese ganzen voraussetzungen die
geschaffen werden müssen bevor im
modernen zusammenhang gearbeitet werden
muss das ist dann die frage bei adam
smith und seine antwort ist wie man sich
denken kann ja das alles ist kapital
kapital ist das angehäufte aus der
vergangenheit mit den ich dann in der
zukunft arbeiten und wirtschaften kann
also das ist dann ein verhältnis das was
bei lok ein bisschen implizit auch da
ist aber dann wesentlichen schritt
weiter geht s los
weil jetzt haben wir dieses system
ein zweifaches system von arbeit auf der
einen seite aber als voraussetzung für
die arbeiten kapital und das
kapitalmanagement ist dann auch kapital
kapital ist reichtum oder eigentum das
in der arbeit
verarbeitet werden kann
und darin
ok also das ist jetzt das wichtige 1 mit
also implizit bei lockes ist auch ist
wie schon gesagt diese kritik an
aristokraten die nichts machen weil sie
viel mehr besitzen als was sie selber
bearbeiten könnten also im test
ebenfalls implizit bei lok obwohl er das
nicht direkt kritisiert bei smith wird
das fiel deutlich für ihn ist die
ursünde sozusagen das einer kapital
besitzt oder dieses kapital anzuwenden
er nennt leute die nichts mit ihrem
reichtum anfangen nennt er pro flag to
flag oder spin trifft also die begriffe
die weiß mit hochkommen und dann ein
beständiges thema bleiben
das ist eher die kritik also dicht an
der nadel
arroganz oder ausbeuterische sonst weiß
sondern daran dass sie nichts machen
oder tendenziell dass sie nichts machen
weil diese ist primär ist aber damit die
arbeit was machen kann braucht sie
kapital und kapital sind die früchte der
vergangene arbeit die in die neuere
gegenwärtige arbeit einfließen und
verwendet werden müssen
also das ist es nichts gibt es
allerdings noch einschränkungen die
nicht so unbedingt so überzeugend sind
dazu werden wir noch kommen aber dass
der fundamentale gitarrist ist kapital
ist etwas was sich in der modernen
gesellschaft entwickelt und insofern
etwas positives ist also das darf man
nicht vergessen das ist sowohl bei
diesen klasse klassischen denkern als
auch bei marks ist kapital ein
analytischer begriff und überhaupt nicht
mit negativität besetzt
kapital ist neutral
also der begriff kapital ist neutral
kapitalismus ist vielleicht weil es
anders oder kapital ist dass das hat
schon negative konnotation aber der
gedanke kapital an sich bezeichnet nur
ein bereich der wirtschaftlichen analyse
die gerade auf die moderne wirtschaft
zutrifft
die moderne wirtschaft entwickelt
kapital und das ist was positives die
frage ist was macht man mit diesem
kapital oder wer besitzt kapital und so
weiter und uns also das sind die fragen
die uns dann den antikapitalisten dann
beschäftigen aber kapital an sich ist
was positiv ist und es ist quasi sowohl
im wissenschaftlichen die entdeckung des
kapitals durch nathan smith als auch die
entwicklung des kapitals in der modernen
industriegesellschaft das darauf
fokussiert sich diese fokussieren sich
diese diese gedanken ein weiterer
klassischer denker auch vorgänger von
fox ist der principe politiker kennen
geschrieben hat ganz hilfreicher text
also wir müssen uns jetzt nicht in allen
einzelheiten philologisch mit
mit der geschichte dieser denke
auseinandersetzen aber ich erwähne john
stuart mill bayer weg wirklich wichtig
ist das ist ein klassischer liberaler
viktorianischer denker so war
beispielsweise ist früher für den
feminismus eingetreten und in seinem
interesse politikerin konan öl verfügt
ja auch eine quasi aufgeklärte
[Musik]
sozialistisch ist es halt nicht aber es
ist ein aufgeklärter liberaler
kapitalismus ja aber mit einschränkungen
wichtig also wenn wir nur eins wir
werden uns damit weiter befassen aber
für john stuart mill
ist das das ist ja eine weiterführung
dessen was bei bayer das mit vorkommt
das war auch er kapital wahnsinnig
wichtig bei john silver s er betont ist
quasi das gute das moralisch aus seiner
sicht ist es schon moral moralischen
bewertung gesetzt das gute am kapital
ist dass es sich schnell zirkuliert also
kapital zirkuliert in dem sinne dass die
voraussetzungen für die arbeit die aus
der vergangenheit gekommen
aus der vergangenheit kommen schnell
verarbeitet werden
und dann zu weiteren gütern entwickelt
werden das ist für john stuart mill
das zeichen eines einer gesunden
wirtschaft was rumliegt sozusagen oder
klassische güter also beispielsweise
ländereien im besitz von irgendwelchen
nachladen legen also das ist könnte
kapital seien aber wird so nicht genutzt
und das ist das ist dann sehr negativ
besetzt business im gegensatz tag so ist
kapital was ständig zirkulieren
einfließt in den kreislauf der
produktion das ist wie etwas positives
und er sagt also kapitalgüter
idealerweise existieren gar nicht lagen
also die werden erst hergestellt und
dann sofort konsumiert also entweder
konsumiert und damit der mensch dann die
basis seiner seines überlebens schaffen
kann oder konsumiert in dem sinne durch
weitere produktive kreisläufe und das
ist etwas positives
ok also das ist das sind diese drei
denke für sie ist kapital und die
entdeckung von arbeit und kapital oder
von der verlinkung zwischen arbeit und
kapital ist die basis einer sichtweise
des modernen lebens die auch stark
moralisch geprägt ist also der gedanke
ist was was den menschen ausmacht ist
eine arbeit was er dafür braucht es
kapital kapital ist etwas modernes wir
sollten dankbar sein dass das existiert
weil wir bauen damit wir stehen auf den
schultern unserer vorgänger sozusagen
oder oder die die gegenwart steht in
einem bereich den die vergangenheit uns
geschenkt hat nein nicht geschenkt aber
jedenfalls zur verfügung gestellt hat
und das sollten wir zelebrieren
ok magst dann in dieser
entwicklungsreihe sieht auch das kapital
grundsätzlich als positiv
meine die moderne gesellschaften
wirtschaft funktioniert halt in dem man
kapital hat wenn man kein kapital hätte
dann ist niemandem gedient
das war ja der eine programmpunkt bei
marx fünf zentrale ist als des kredits
man sollte krediten
die frage ist dann natürlich wem gehört
kapital
das ist dann ein bereich wo sich die
geschichte bei marx dann verschiebt aber
der gedanke dass das der staat kapital
haben besitzen sollte und zur verfügung
stellen sollte ist nicht nur bei marx
drinnen sondern gewissermaßen auch
seither oder war schon damals
selbstverständlich ist nur die frage wo
ist die trennlinie zwischen staatlichem
kapital und privatem kapital okay aber
das lassen wir jetzt erstmal was mag sie
zu bringen mit denen sicherlich auch
bekannt sein
zu diesen gedanken seiner vorgänger ist
seine vorgänger aussehen seine vorgänger
rwe soll seine vorgänger hin gehen auch
davon aus dass innerhalb der dynamik des
kapitals sich bestimmte entwicklungen
feststellen lassen
vor allem die fallen sinkende profitrate
das ist etwas was seine vorgänger auch
in diversen formen festgestellt hatten
oder dachten sie würden feststellen
also das kapital immer weniger profit
abwirft
das sieht man schon bei das mit und bei
ricardo auch in england trotz seines
namens und das ist eine dynamik
innerhalb des kapitalismus oder das der
wirtschaft dem mit kapital weise marx
hat dann gesagt ja gut also das wird
dazu führen dass das kabel dass diese
gesellschaftsstruktur nicht nachhaltig
sein wird
und wegen dieser fehlenden
nachhaltigkeit wird es zwangsläufig zu
einer zur gesellschaftlichen umwälzungen
führen okay also das ist ein element das
ist bei den vorgängern nicht präsent
also der gedanke dass es werden
gesellschaftliche umwälzungen kommen und
das hat er dann wie wir wissen
hygienisch eingepackt also hier gilt es
gedanke dass quasi das die welt
insgesamt in einem umfassenden
entwicklungs vorgang erfasst wird
also hier gewiss hegels gedanke der
geschichte wie sie wahrscheinlich wissen
ist dass das ist die zwangsläufige
entwicklungen gibt hin zu einem
letztjährigen ziel und diese
entwicklungen erfassen so quasi alle ist
nicht nur die pragmatischen fragen des
täglichen lebens oder die politischen
fragen oder internationale konflikte
oder sonstwas sondern unser bewusstsein
und so für hier ist die geschichte auch
eine entwicklung des bewusstseins das
ist etwas was man so wahrnimmt in
zweierlei hinsicht erstens weil er dann
sagt innerhalb der desg dieser
gesellschaftsordnung also er sagt nicht
kapitalismus also für ihn ist es die mit
das spannungsverhältnis zwischen der
bourgeoisie und dem politiker dass sie
die bourgeoisie der bourgeoisie gehört
alles uns insbesondere die
produktionsverhältnisse die fabriken und
die banken und es grund und boden und so
weiter und hat und auf der anderen seite
sind die politiker denen nichts gehört
außer ihrer arbeitskraft und die
spannung zwischen diesen beiden sagt
marx hebräisch als kriegerischer
perspektive
diese spannung wird sich im laufe der
geschichte zu einer explosion weiter
entwickeln also den fehlenden
nachhaltigkeit des kapitalismus für marx
wird sich in diesen sozialen die
spannungsverhältnisse dann
zeigen das ist das eine das andere ist
der einfluss hegels der andere aspekt
ist wie gesagt der gedanke des
bewusstseins für marx ist ein aspekt der
geschichte des wandelnde bewusstsein des
menschen in dem sinne nicht nur dass er
das quasi boden sich abwechseln oder mal
ließ man dieses mal dies mal jenen oder
ich weiß nicht was also bewusst sein in
dem es im sinne von konsumenten
präferenzen da ist meint er nicht also
bewusstsein ist wie ich überhaupt mein
leben verstehen oder oder wie ich mein
leben wahrnehmen wie ich die welt
wahrnehme und das ist etwas was bei
marks eine zunehmende rolle spielt unter
dem aspekt der ideologie also ideologie
wird beim horx eingeführt was das ganze
ideengebäude was mit bestimmten
gesellschaftlichen verhältnissen
einhergeht
das ist in der klasse in den bei den
klassischen denkern absolut nicht
präsent aber für marx es ist sind es
dann nicht nur die entwicklungen
es ist nicht nur die dynamik des
kapitals selbst also
wirtschaftswissenschaftliche fragen
sondern darüber hinaus kommt diese wie
er sagt dieser überbau des sich
wandelnden bewusstseins also der
proletarier also sagen denkt anders als
der bursche bisschen corp gesagt aber
und er sagt die herrschen
sie kennen ja diese diesen ausdruck die
herrschenden ideen jeder epoche sind die
ideen der herrschenden ja das ist auch
ein slogan der 68 ok dann jetzt ich
mache jetzt gleich schluss weil ich
generell nicht mehr als maximal 60
minuten rede lieber nur 45
ja so ist es einfach so lange wollen sie
mir nicht zuhören letzte letzter punkt
an dem handy
die beiden letzten autoren adorno und
habermas
es ist dieses letzte element der sich
gerade angesprochen habe nämlich
ideologie und bewusst sein dass dann im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert
ganz wichtig wird und der gedanke ist
dann also gerade bei meinem trainer und
habermas bezeichnen übrigens ist das
sind natürlich wissenschaftler die
anderen seien also lok war mediziner
letzten jahr war schon wissenschaftler
john stuart mill
parlamentsmitglied wie auch ricardo den
der hin steht
das englische parlament es ist schon
sehr deutlich dass diese beiden adorno
und habermas als einer ist der
perspektive einer hochschule kommen und
deren oder sie nicht nur bei denen
sondern in den acht 60er 70er jahren war
diese überlegung ja also wenn die
herrschende idee herrschen denn ideen
alle die ideen der herrschenden center
nicht will aber nicht wirklich der
herrschen dann sagen dann wo kriege ich
meine ideen her sozusagen also was ist
dann
wie sieht es aus wenn man sich von der
ideologie befreien will ideologiekritik
war damals das schlagwort in deutschland
ist das überhaupt möglich
und wie sieht es dann aus also wie komme
ich raus aus dieser ideologie also wenn
ich einmal sage ja mit marx oder hegel
gewissermaßen alles was sie denken und
tun wollen und und planen ist bestimmt
durch meine so meine gesellschaft meine
gesellschaftlichen status und als als
hochschul mit leben bin ich ziemlich
groß war wie komme ich da überhaupt aus
und diese diese form von arbeit ja die
befreiung aus den schlechten zeiten des
kapitalismus läuft einher mit einer
befreiung von den bewusstseins mäßigen
einschränkungen das ist so ein bisschen
sehr summarisch das thema
dieser beiden doch noch ein halber muss
natürlich viel mehr als das und ja wir
werden dann sehen wie das ausgearbeitet
wird aber was wichtig ist also weder
adorno nach habermas haben sich große
gedanken großartige gedanken gemacht
über die dynamik des capital ist im
gegensatz zu den klassischen kind kann
und im gegensatz zu marx ist also da
wird mehr oder weniger davon ausgegangen
ja so ist es halt
vielleicht funktioniert vielleicht
vielleicht nicht wir müssen wir können
nur hoffen
in den beiträgen zur wand denn damit
auch keiner herausgegeben hat dialektik
der aufklärung also adorno kritisiert
dann schon sehr stark das was er als
einen also den begriff des homo
ökonomischer ist der den begriff dass
der mensch letztendlich nur ein
[Musik]
ausdruck seiner ökonomischen interessen
ist das hat er stark kritisiert näher
ran an die funktionsweise des capital
ist ist er nicht gekommen
insofern also das werden wir alles noch
sehen ich würde dann sofern wir das
nicht schon in der lektüre liste drin
haben ihnen noch ganz kurz empfehlen
also im law blog ist ich würde ihm schon
also wenn sie zeit haben gleich mehrere
spezialisten aber es würde sich lohnen
und lockt ist ein zweites tag tat über
das regierung dass ich eigentlich alles
aber es ist natürlich im ca
langes werk da müssen wir halt sehen die
welt weiter wie wir da weiterkommen
sonst wird mir ebenfalls große britische
economist ist viel zu lang
was dass sie das in einem aufwasch in
angriff nehmen könnten
bei jetzt bei den neueren aber weil
dortmund habermas die ich ihnen zwei
aufsätze vorschlagen von adornos
dialektik der aufklärung und wie gesagt
das ist ein sammelband den auf sadismus
oder mythos und aufklärung also da
kommen seine kommt seine kritik adornos
kritik an den homo oeconomicus sehr
deutlich und sehr schön zum ausdruck
es ist nur ein segment ein teil kurzer
teil in diesem diesem sammelband das
können sie schnell lesen bei habermas
für die philosophen interessant ist der
aufsatz wahrheit' theorien aus dem jahr
1972 aber wie gesagt das ist also da
brauchen sie schon dem bis in die
philosophischen voraussetzung denn sonst
wird es ihnen nicht so viel sagen aber
eine andere möglichkeit auch sehr kurz
sind ein paar bekommen die auf einer
tagung gemacht seit im jahr 1973 da ist
es rolle der philosophie im marxismus
und da hat er einige stichpunkte aber
was einige stichpunkte angeführt die
ganze hilfreich sind in diesem
zusammenhang
okay wer wollte ich heute nichts sagen
sie können mir gerne fragen stellen die
die veranstaltung geht theoretisch noch
bis dreiviertel 2 aber sie müssen nicht
bleiben und sie müssen auch keine fragen
stellen aber wenn sie wollen